how do you manage the security and
compliance of your cloud workloads hi my
name is janet van from ibm and i'm here
to talk about cloud security posture
management also known as
cspm
cloud security data breaches are a
common place today with most breaches
involving a misconfiguration of an error
or result of a cloud misconfiguration
misconfigurations are generally created
in the initial setup or during the
lifetime of a cloud deployment
with more organizations moving their
legacy workloads
to the cloud
it becomes more important than ever
to have security compliance management
and automated remediation in your cloud
infrastructure
cspm
is a group of security tools and
technologies that empowers security
users to be able to identify and
remediate
risk and misconfigurations in their
cloud environments
we will review
how cspm is the solution to security and
compliance management in your cloud
resources
to start let's review some key
capabilities a cspm tool can have
it can offer
the ability of continuous
compliance monitoring
of your cloud resources
so that you can identify and remediate
risks and areas such as storage buckets
encryption
and permissions
to follow it can also offer
policy-based
definitions and consistent enforcement
of who can access what data to help
reduce risk and ensure that compliance
standards are met
another
is security
and threat detection
to identify risks that could compromise
your cloud network
and last but not least
remediation
the ability to immediately and
intuitively identify
risk and resolve compliance violations
all these key capabilities and more help
security teams who are responsible for
securing their clouds
infrastructure some of the key benefits
of utilizing a cspm tool includes
providing visibility
into their cloud infrastructure
and as well as assets and security
configurations
so that security teams now have one
place to assess
across multiple cloud environments and
accounts
while providing it through a centralized
dashboard that can give actionable
metrics as well as training behaviors
another is evidence
this is provided by the mapping of your
cloud's infrastructure
to
regulatory standards
security control frameworks as well as
internal security policies
to help maintain your cloud's compliance
as well as being able to ensure that the
gathering of evidence is done for
security audits
another important piece is the ability
to provide reporting and alerting
a comprehensive report can be provided
of your cloud's risk posture as well as
the alerting notifications that can be
brought to your attention so that it
identifies risks so it can have
investigation remediation done as soon
as possible
and one of the most important features
of
a cspm tool is automation
auto remediation automated remediation
helps security teams reduce the time and
effort required for manual remediation
as well as evidence gathering
all these key capabilities and benefits
help security teams today be able to
really focus on the security and
compliance of their compliance of their
cloud infrastructure
we learned csvm tools are an important
critical part to securing cloud
environments and reducing the
possibility of a security data breach
thank you for joining me and if you have
any questions please drop us a line
below
and if you want to see more videos like
this in the future please like and
subscribe